[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
opening statements bring to light the
gruesome details of the tote family
murders out of florida everybody needed
to die
in order to pass over to the other side
together because the apocalypse was
coming and there's never been any
acceptance of responsibility for your
actions mr edcom a sentence is handed
down in the deadly road rage shooting
trial out of wisconsin plus these doses
of fentanyl
that the defendant gave
order to be given prescribed
to these victims
this is the cause of their death
closing arguments are presented by both
sides in the case of accused murderer
former ohio doctor william hussell but
first i'm here in support of johnny depp
i believe that he's innocent we're live
in virginia as actors johnny depp and
amber heard go head to head in a
defamation lawsuit law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer jury
selection begins in virginia as
hollywood a-listers johnny depp and
amber heard face off in a multi-million
dollar defamation lawsuit that's where
law and crime's angel levy joins us now
live with the latest developments from
day one internet
well brian that jury was selected
relatively quickly here at the fairfax
county courthouse in less than one day
and those jurors will hear our opening
statements on tuesday morning in this
high profile hollywood defamation case
that has been years in the making
bright and early johnny depp fans lined
the walkway of the fairfax county
courthouse hoping to get a glimpse of
the actor some holding signs that said
justice for johnny it means getting
justice for somebody who is framed for
something that he didn't do
and he doesn't deserve to lose roles he
doesn't deserve to lose any of that over
lies christina gibbons brought her four
children from minnesota to support depp
the movie star is suing ex-wife amber
heard for defamation dupp says it
happened in late 2018 when the
washington post published this op-ed
from heard where she wrote about being a
victim of domestic abuse her didn't name
depp but he says that doesn't matter
because everyone knew who she was
talking about depp filed suit seeking 50
million dollars saying the op-ed cost
him acting jobs virginia lawyer gene
rossi on depth's claim the burden of
proof is much tougher for a plaintiff
like johnny depp
he has to prove
that his former wife amber heard
maliciously with reckless disregard for
the truth
made an allegation that he essentially
engaged in life-beating and domestic
abuse hurt is counter suing for 100
million dollars she says depp defamed
her by calling her a perjurer and a hoax
artist one of the greatest movies of all
time is uh animal house and there's that
famous scene with john belushi and
there's a food fight and everybody's
fighting uh this is a um ex
ex-spouse's food fight the testimony
will certainly thrust the intimate
details of depp and heard's tumultuous
relationship into the spotlight heard
posted on instagram last weekend about
going offline for several weeks writing
hopefully when this case concludes i can
move on and so can johnny out of all of
the fans outside the courthouse only one
was there to show support for heard
we're here to support amber hurd because
social media operations are harming her
and so we're not able to support her the
remaining fans outside the courthouse
say they don't believe herd's
allegations of abuse i believe the truth
is that johnny isn't this
wife-beating monster that amber says
that he is and i want the world to know
that
and you may be asking yourself why is
this case being heard here in the
commonwealth of
virginia at the fairfax county
courthouse and there's a very simple
answer for that johnny depp and his
lawyers wrote in the lawsuit that they
were filing it here because the
washington post is published here in
virginia and there the servers for the
company's website are in virginia as
well uh some located here in fairfax
county so that is why johnny depp chose
virginia
this commonwealth here in which to file
this lawsuit brian
makes sense thanks angelette joining us
today is criminal defense attorney karen
nance and co-host terry austin karen
dempster depp's defamation comes from
the harm he says he suffered from hurm's
essay on the post but like we heard he
wasn't named so how is he arguing this
harm
well the article that was written was
after the party's divorced they were
married from 2015 to 2017 and in that
divorce she argues that
one of the reasons or the main reason
was domestic abuse so he's making that
leap and i don't think it's too far of a
leap that um the reference in the the
post article was regarding the uh
allegations she had made in their
divorce so that's how uh the link is
made there all right so a bit of a leap
but i would agree it kind of makes sense
there terry as gene kind of told us this
case involved two high profile figures
different standards based on the law but
based on your experience in public
relations how do you think that will
affect their case
brian there's a famous quote by bill
gates and that quote is if i was down to
my last dollar i would spend it on
public relations your public image is
critical and if the public loves you his
chances of winning in court is much
better and it absolutely seems and it
was based on anjanet's you know
reporting there that everybody is
backing johnny depp that people look at
her as though she is an opportunist and
that she's making this information up so
right now in terms of the pr johnny depp
is way ahead well everyone but one and
of course we want to hear from our fans
of course if you support either side in
this case and jeanette we're expecting a
star-studded witness list in this trial
what can you tell us about who's
expected to testify
well there are a number of people on the
witness list for both sides amber hurd
is expected to call elon musk and actor
james franco they are expected to
testify if they do via zoom and then
johnny depp is expected to call paul
bettany to testify on his behalf so
there are going to be some high profile
names uh coming up in this case and of
course johnny depp and amber heard are
both expected to testify all right it's
going to give us a lot of insight into
the relationship and we'll see if these
uh star-studded casts end up coming down
to virginia thank you very much anjanet
for your coverage still ahead on law and
crime daily a sentence is handed down in
the road rage trial of theodore edge
code but first closing arguments are
finally expected as ex-icu doctor
william hussell stands trial for the
alleged murder of his patients
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
jury's dismissed in the trial for former
icu doctor william hussell this came
monday just before the prosecution began
as closing arguments husel is charged
with the deaths of 14 of his patients
for allegedly ordering fatal doses of
fentanyl during his time as a physician
in mount carmel hospital's intensive
care unit prosecutors claimed the doses
were excessive and accelerated the
deaths who sales defense argues he was
providing comfort care to the dying
patients after about six weeks of
testimony and 53 witnesses the defense
called only one person to testify then a
day-by-day pause that lasted a week as a
motion was filed in an attempt to get
the judge removed but that was
ultimately denied monday morning before
closing arguments began a juror was
dismissed after the judge said it was
clear he was been paying attention to
media reports then the prosecution began
its closing argument
there could be more than one cause
and if the defendant's actions
is one of those causes
it's not an offense that something else
would have killed them
these doses of fentanyl
that the defendant gave
order to be given prescribed
to these victims
this is the cause of their death folks
even though they were very critically
ill
and perhaps some of them were on a
trajectory to die very soon anyways
you cannot hasten their death
you cannot quickly
painlessly
cause the death
of a dying person
monday afternoon the defense presented
its final plea to the jury saying the
prosecution did not prove their case
there was not one shred of evidence
submitted to you
as to why we're all here
why
will this man risk his family
his career
17 years of trying to be a doctor every
single thing he has worked for
to hasten someone's death or to kill
them
specifically to kill them
now you have a tough job because this is
such a unique case
it's a novel prosecution
the mere fact of taking someone off life
support as you've all learned
is hasting their death
and not a single person has testified to
you
as to how long they would have lived
without the fentanyl
for the delighted person
how can you say he's gonna hasten
someone's death
if you don't know how long they had to
begin with
all right terry it's the million dollar
question do you think this was comfort
care or do you think william hussell is
a murderer
you know what brian i've said this all
along and my humble opinion i think
based on the volumes of evidence that dr
hughes will provided comfort care and i
think that some of the jury is going to
think the same thing once your vital
signs are going down once you start
seeing your loved one grasping for air
or maybe they're wincing in pain you are
going to say yes please provide this
comfort care and dr hussell did what all
of the others were doing it might have
been different doses
no one disagreed with him and frankly i
think it was the right decision at the
time they may have questioned the
methodology but i think he did the right
thing and i think there might be some
reasonable doubt in this case
karen jose baez as we saw there kind of
touched on this issue the prosecution
really never gave us a motive for these
crimes now they don't have to it's not a
part of the case or any case but do you
think that hurts their case in any way
i yes i definitely do and i agree 100
with terry's view of the case what bias
did was very
ingenious i believe in terms of how he
presented it we had no causation we had
no intent in addition he indicated and
stated pretty strongly that there is no
maximum dosage of fentanyl he did focus
on that in addition he indicated that
the majority of the the nurses sided
with dr fusel in this particular uh
houston i'm sorry in this particular
case so i believe he was a presented a
very compelling argument to the jury
all right we'll see how it goes because
on one end i get it from the prosecution
why do you give fentanyl why to give
this much fentanyl but as any good
defense attorney does jose baez is
coming in and kind of just poking tiny
holes there both of you are saying a
potential hung jury we'll see how it
plays out thankfully we finally got
closing arguments in this case but we'll
continue to follow it here in the law on
crime daily giving you updates on the
trial as it progresses coming up on law
on crime daily a father accused of
killing his wife children and the family
pet faces a jury for the first day of
trial in florida as the prosecution
begins its case plus how long will a man
convicted of killing a wisconsin
attorney spend in jail that's next as
theodore edgecombe learns his fate
[Music]
welcome back months after a guilty
verdict is handed down convicted killer
theodore edgecombe is sentenced in the
road rage trial out of wisconsin in
january edgecone was found guilty of
first-degree reckless homicide
edgecombe's conviction stems from the
september 2020 death of jason clearman a
milwaukee immigration attorney edgcomb
says he was riding his bike when
clearman and his wife swiped him with
their car video footage shows edgecombe
punching clearman through the open
passenger side window after that the car
follows edgecone security footage shows
clairman eventually get out of the car
and confront the defendant that's when
edgecombe shot him he was arrested six
months later in kentucky while edgecomb
always maintained self-defense he
testified quote the gun just went off
before handing down a sentence judge
david borelski addressed edgecombe's
testimony
was not particularly
to
credible
that and you said it repeatedly
understand the gun just went off
when what the testimony was from
multiple eyewitnesses
was that you pulled up your hand and
went like
this right at the forehead of the victim
and shot the victim almost directly
between the eyes that's not an accident
that's not a gun just going off
that's you brandishing a weapon and
pointing it at someone's temple i'm
sensing the defendant as follows largely
following the state's recommendation 25
years of initial confinement
12 years of extended supervision
terry the judge almost implied there
that this was a cold-blooded murder do
you agree you know what brian i agree in
part and i disagree in part i think when
edgecombe pulled that trigger he was
aiming to kill and it did look like it
was cold-blooded but that initial claim
of self-defense that was plausible he
was trying to escape he felt he was
cornered and he was trying to defend
himself the problem here is he got up
there and he said it was an accident you
can't accidentally shoot someone when
you're claiming self-defense you're
either trying to defend yourself or you
are not so he put himself in that
position and that's why the judge gave
him 25 and i kind of agree with that
yeah let's kind of talk about 25 years
karen because i get the final moments as
the judge is describing but before that
he's kind of running for his life
edgecomb so for a case that didn't seem
completely one-sided are you shocked
about the sentence here
well it could have been worse i mean the
jury could have come back with first
degree and they didn't they came back
with reckless homicide i think that i
would put the onus on the defense
counsel in making that determination of
calling edgecomb as a witness now would
he have been successful without
testifying at all with regard to
self-defense probably not but at the
same time more coaching and sometimes
you just can't as a defensive attorney
coach your your client in terms of how
to answer questions but the judge
indicated that he did not find
edgecombe's testimony as being credible
with regard to the accident claim so i
think that that didn't help him at all
with with that with the jury's finding
they found him not credible with that
but in that regard yeah and that one
statement was very problematic not just
for for the judges pointing at but also
for a self-defense claim this seems like
a situation where maybe the defense
should have prepped him a little bit
more and if he couldn't get to that
point maybe as you said karen he doesn't
testify but again hindsight being 20 20
we're not sure how that would have ended
up but thank you both when we come back
a quadruple family murder just miles
from walt disney world what new details
are revealed as opening statements are
presented
[Music]
welcome back years after quadruple
murder and multiple trial delays opening
statements are finally presented in the
case of florida versus anthony toad the
man accused of murdering his wife three
young children and their family dog
it happened in early 2020 just miles
from disney world in celebration florida
that's where prosecutors say 45 year old
anthony tow murdered his family
investigators found their bodies weeks
after they were killed when officials
attempted to arrest tote on unrelated
charges of insurance fraud in a
jailhouse letter to his father tote
claimed his wife was to blame for the
killings on monday prosecutors described
a potential motive behind the murder
spree and revealed tote spent days in
the master bedroom with the bodies of
his family members leading up to his
arrest
you're going to be
informed by the defendant in his
interview
that he is the one that took the lives
of meghan tote
alexander tyler tote and zoe tov went
into zoe toad's room while she was
asleep
and he took the time to
sit with her
and then he rolled over on top of her
until she suffocated
the evidence will show that he did the
same thing to tyler tote that he did to
alexander toe
he suffocated tyler tow
and he also stabbed tyler tote in the
abdomen the defendant in his interview
says that
megan toad and himself had an agreement
that
everybody needed to die
in order to pass over to the other side
together because the apocalypse was
coming
right before he suffocated and took the
life of megan tote
that he also suffocated breezy the dog
and then the defendant says that
after everybody was dead
he took all of their bodies and placed
them all into the master bedroom
defense attorneys did not present an
opening statement on monday a common
strategy amongst defense attorneys the
trial judge told jurors defense
attorneys will have an opportunity to
present an opening later in the trial
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney karen nance and co-host terry
austin as we get into the tote family
murder karen what do you call the
smoking gun in this case
that the prosecution will try to hang
their hat on to convict so
well i think
there are several first is that he was
in the home when when the investigators
came to the house to arrest him on an
unrelated charge and then all the bodies
were there then we have the two
confessions of course one of them was
excluded but we still have a confession
to use and third the
fingerprints his fingerprints were on
the bottles of of the uh the the drug i
believe it was benadryl and so those
things uh really uh actually
make it a very very difficult uphill
case for the for the defense
absolutely now tara i think i heard a
little bit of like doomsday end of time
sounds like a little lori vallo dave out
here i know you like that case as well
but we heard opening statements and
several witnesses for the state so far
have you heard any evidence supporting
the defense argument that the wife may
be responsible for the deaths
you know what this case is moving very
quickly if you blinked you may have
missed it the prosecution mentioned it
in the opening and you heard her say it
there that there was an agreement
between the defendant and the wife whose
name is megan that they wanted to make
sure they kill themselves because the
apocalypse was coming and they have to
all pass at the same time but then we
did hear the voice of chrissy caplet
that is the defendant's sister she made
a call to 9-1-1 it was following up on a
wellness check and the prosecution
actually played that recording and in
the recording she said she spoke to the
wife megan and the wife megan did say
something about the end of the world so
there's at least a little bit of
evidence in there it's been introduced
that supports that defendant's position
that it was his wife's idea as well
all right we'll see how this plays out
maybe that element is one murder but not
them both uh thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you